j'accueille Jean-Pierre rive
[Musique]
rire encore Yves toujours
oui hier casque d'or ratissé tous les
ballons et à balayer toute la pelouse du
Parc des Princes un des racines arables
rive c'est imposé aussi par sa présence
ce petit plus qui en fait un grand RIB à
horreur qu'on lui marche dessus même si
un terrain de rugby n'est pas un salon
où l'on échange des douceurs quelques
australiens s'y sont piquets et marquer
là il n'est pas encore revenu de la
façon de rive de lui serrer la main
parce que Jean-Pierre arrive a fait un
grand match vous savez ce que je fais ce
que je ne fais pas c'est pas très
important pourtant c'est de gagner parce
que c'est ce que tous les garçons ont
mérité je suis très heureux pour eux un
de mes confrères a dit Jean-Pierre rive
a les cheveux de plus en plus long et le
souffle de plus en plus court qu'est-ce
que vous répondriez à ce qu'on fait si
vous étiez à la place de Jean-Pierre
Rives pendant mes gonflés toi
c'est gonflé
[Musique]
tout le monde en a parlé à retrouver
Jean-Pierre riche près de Sainte-Maxime
dans le sud-est de la France il est
aujourd'hui sculpteur et nous présente
son œuvre
du monumental du brut de l'original tu
prends les trucs à Trappes comme ça là
des poules tu sais attraper les bars
je fais ça je fais ça alors on me dit
pourquoi pourquoi tu fais ça parce que
c'est je sais pas faire autre chose
puisque j'ai arrêté une activité pour me
consacrer à une autre un art qui lui a
permis d'accéder au rang d'Officier de
l'Ordre National du Mérite il a trouvé
un style qui lui correspond complètement
une petite ferraille en fait une œuvre
d'art magnifique légère et dans la vie
il est comment casque d'or transforme
une un petit univers univers un univers
de rêve c'est un rêveur un poète
c'est un homme très un homme génial
le petit blanc là il s'appelle Kino et
le bottes
même sa vie de sculpteur Jean-Pierre
veut la vivre en équipe il nous emmène
maintenant dans l'atelier de l'un de ses
amis artistes
ah ça c'est bien c'est bien ça
c'est marrant comment tu fais oui oui tu
sais qu'il faut faire attention quand
même le plan
il y a ton âge justement il faut qu'on
fasse nous attention
j'ai des amis qui sont des sculpteurs
qui n'ont pas joué au rugby j'ai des
amis qui aujourd'hui qui n'ont pas fait
de sculpture mais enfin quand on est
tous ensemble on part de la même chose
c'est l'invention qui nous intéresse
aujourd'hui Jean-Pierre riff qui
temporairement le monde de la sculpture
pour retrouver ses copains du rugby
direction Paris pour la conférence de
presse des barbariens club de rugby VIP
il retrouve Denis Charvet ancienne
gloire du XV de France lui aussi
[Musique]
très près Jean-Pierre dans son évolution
son évolution aussi artistique et comme
il a ça a été dur mais si il est il
s'est donné à fond comme son affront
dans tout ce qui entreprend
s'imposer en tant que Jean-Pierre c'est
formidable le célèbre Serge Blanco est
tout aussi admiratif de son ancien
collègue de terrain c'est fort de
pouvoir repartir pour quitter un arc
pour partir dans un autre parmi les
invités max wadini président du Stade
Français
c'est une personnalité très très fort
dans le rugby qui a priori était courant
de rien mais qui sait tout qui connaît
tout qui a des débiles arrêtés juste
d'ailleurs et Jean-Pierre parle de son
art à toute heure dans le dos c'est
mieux
plus près non
c'est super
mais pour l'instant on fête un
anniversaire je suis là et au nom de
tous mes petits camarades pour
pour vous annoncer que le BRC le barbare
[Musique]
Jean-Pierre rive n'est certes pas un
grand orateur mais cela ne l'empêche pas
de dire ce qu'il pense n'en déplaise à
certains on n'a jamais parlé un agent on
connaît pas le nom des agents pour le
moment et on espère que c'est pas le
rester parce que nous les bavards on
veut pas parler avec des agents on peut
parler avec des présidents on va les
gens du rugby on va pas parler avec les
gens de du commerce voilà
moi je serais plus président
il est temps de passer au collation
au bar il retrouve ses anciens
coéquipiers fin connaisseur de sa
carrière qui le soutiennent dans cette
reconversion artistique
[Musique]
il a ce ballon ovale heureux hasard en
contrebasse se dresse une sculpture
d'Albert Ferrand
c'est lui qui a donné à Jean-Pierre
l'envie de sculpter
c'est formidable après avoir inscrit son
nom dans l'épopée du rugby et
Jean-Pierre Yves laissera-t-il une trace
dans le monde de l'art
et maintenant la lumière sera allume sur
Jean-Pierre Rives
bienvenue dans tout le monde en a parlé
Jean-Pierre bonsoir alors vous êtes né
le 31 décembre 1952 à Saint-Simon dans
la banlieue de Toulouse votre père était
militaire de carrière et il travaillait
sur la base aérienne de Toulouse il
était pilote de l'Armée de l'Air voilà
alors famille de sportifs votre
grand-père était champion de vélo oui
c'est examen alors vos parents c'était
le tennis et vous au départ vous
commencez à jouer au tennis et vous vous
mettez au rugby parce que votre cousin
Jean-Louis il y a le prof de gym
monsieur Cassagne absolument je suis
passé à travers la
vitre du gymnase et il en a conclu que
j'avais quelques aptitudes pour jouer en
réalité voilà il m'a dit vas-y viens et
puis je suis arrivé dans dans un club
qui s'appelait le toit voilà alors le
Toulouse Olympique employé club qui est
une sorte d'université populaire du
rugby quartier des Minimes là où où
habitait Nougaro d'ailleurs absolument
et là on m'a dit prends le ballon et on
m'a trouvé quelques qualités on m'a dit
il faut revenir la semaine prochaine et
voilà puis ça s'est jamais arrêté après
il y a eu beau moment l'aumagne alors
Beaumont le même c'est un gros village à
une cinquantaine de kilomètres de
Toulouse et qui pratiquait le rugby
comme un culte et qui était en première
division c'est un village de 4000
habitants il y avait 8000 personnes au
stade on sait pas devenait c'était
formidable une expérience magnifique où
j'ai gardé des amis merveilleux alors
ensuite Stade Toulousain et en 1975
l'équipe de France alors les Français
tombent alors sous le charme et on voit
partout des photos de vous couvert
debout et de sang et vous dites c'est
vrai j'ai souvent du sang sur mon
maillot mais c'est le mien je sais pas
si c'est moi qui l'ai dit mais sur
l'autre si c'est pas moi c'est Roger
Couderc
justement à la télé fait beaucoup pour
votre starification Roger Couderc c'est
lui qui a trouvé le le surnom de Casque
d'or c'est Roger qui est
qui m'a fabriqué après est-ce qu'il y a
quelqu'un à la télévision qui a fait
autant pour un sport que Roger Couderc
pour le rugby on devrait lui faire une
statue oui
il est absolument il a fait oui à tout
le monde alors quand Jacques Fourroux
prend sa retraite vous devenez le
capitaine courage des Tricolores encore
du rejet Couderc on m'a téléphoné à 1h
du matin en me disant tu sais
Jean-Pierre tu vas être capitaine équipe
de France je dis si c'est pour me
disparaît laissez-moi dormir et puis au
milieu non c'est très sérieux et j'ai
dit on va essayer puis voilà et puis ça
a duré un petit moment ça a bien marché
alors on va pas tout refaire parce que
c'est une aventure incroyable mais le
sommet c'est le 14 juillet 1979 avec le
15 de France face à la Nouvelle-Zélande
c'est la première fois que la France
battait la Nouvelle-Zélande on aimerait
miracle
vous aviez quand même entraîné les mecs
pendant une semaine dans la forêt enfin
on était prêt pour pour rentrer à la
maison pas pour jouer vraiment mais
alors évidemment ce qui est le plus
incroyable dans cette histoire c'est le
public deckland qui vous auvacionne
comme si c'était leur équipe qui avait
gagné vous dites ce jour-là j'ai pris la
plus grande leçon de sport de ma vie on
n'a pas beaucoup l'habitude surtout en
fin de les pays latins de voir ce ce
type de réaction et ces gens sont d'une
grande
civilité ils sont ils sont extrêmement
sportifs la Nouvelle-Zélande c'est
certainement le pays du rugby c'est s'il
est né quelque part le rugby il est né
là et des gens aiment leur rugby avant
tout
et c'était quelque chose on s'est senti
on avait gagné un miracle mais
je suis parti de là en disant merci
excusez-nous
d'avoir gagné parce que on se sentait
tellement petit au milieu c'est de ces
gens là enfin moi c'est le souvenir que
j'allais alors vous dites c'est ça le
rugby l'histoire d'un ballon avec des
copains autour et quand il y a plus le
ballon il reste les amis c'est le rubis
a quand même cette
particularité par rapport à d'autres
sports d'être un vrai une vraie
confrérie quoi une vraie coffret c'est à
dire que le jeu même oblige vous oblige
à avoir une certaine attitude parce que
c'est en fait c'est un sport unique dans
le sens où c'est un sport de combat mais
un sport d'équipe et c'est rare il y a
des sports de combat il y a des sports
d'équipe mais les deux en même temps
c'est difficile alors ça crée des liens
un peu spéciaux et quand on a fait la
guerre ensemble les garçons surtout
j'aime pas bien se quitter donc il reste
longtemps copain et c'est le cas alors
toujours potes les mecs de l'époque
alors hormis l'Afrique du Sud vous avez
battu toutes les grandes nations du du
rugby mondial vous êtes le premier
rugbyman à être devenu une personnalité
du sport français quels ont été les
réactions de votre entourage vos parents
par exemple mes parents sont restés
assez assez neutres mon père a ses notes
c'est un joueur de tennis donc le rugby
c'était quelque chose qui qui regardait
mais qui
je crois pas qu'il est non propos je
crois qu'il aurait aimé que je sois
plutôt joueur de tennis donc si je suis
quelque part un échec pour lui
maintenant je dis ça je plaisante mais
je le salue parce que j'aime bien
formidable et il me manque et toujours
maman et merveilleuse qui et qui venait
pas au match et la seule fois elle est
venue elle me chercher sur un stade qui
est un stade de foot donc c'est vous
dire qu'elle était à peu près on
connaissait rien aux règles mais non
c'est mes parents sont restés ce qu'ils
étaient ils n'ont pas ils n'ont pas
changé il suffit d'intéresser à ma mère
c'est que quand je prenais des couilles
je dirais ce que tu as pas mal voilà où
est-ce que tu as mal c'est un peu tout
ça et quand je rentrais le soir mais
c'est où est-ce qu'ils t'ont tapé
des réflexes du moment avec les médias
ça se passait comment sur ce passé très
bien c'était assez c'était très amical
aujourd'hui c'est beaucoup plus organisé
il y a des conférences de presse tout
est devenu très professionnel à l'époque
ont déjeuné avec les uns on faisait la
fête avec les autres ils rentrent
d'investir maintenant j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu plus compliqué pour eux
la question conquête amoureuse ça vous a
aidé ces photos c'est beaucoup faut dire
que de passer à la télévision ça aide
vous en savez quelque chose peut-être je
sais pas mais non ça aide beaucoup le
rugby est un peu la télévision aussi ça
aide beaucoup alors le meilleur moment
de toute votre carrière c'est quoi il y
en a eu tellement puissiez pas tellement
des moments je crois que dans le rugby
ce sont les gens autant on peut oublier
les moments mais je me rappelle de tous
les gens avec qui avec qui j'ai fait un
bout de route et ça a toujours été
quelque chose et c'est et c'est ça cette
espèce de fraternité du jeu vous savez
qu'on soit conçoit Buenos Aires ou en
Nouvelle-Zélande en Afrique du Sud quand
c'est Quinquin et la bagarre c'est la
bagarre et ça sert mais après la bagarre
il y a toujours eu des grandes des
grandes fêtes des grandes soirées et le
pire moment
le pire moment c'est certainement le
jour on arrête cette chose là parce que
on vous enlève votre jouet mais bon moi
j'ai eu la chance de d'avoir d'autres
d'autres passions d'autres
intéressement on va dire mais c'est ça
c'est dur quand on existe que pour ça
qu'on est fait pour ça et qu'on est en
force on devient une machine à ça et les
jours où ça s'arrête c'est difficile
faut faire avec il y en a qui gère plus
ou moins bien vous arrêtez au soir d'une
défaite contre les cosses un mur et fils
vous décidez de quitter l'équipe de
France et vous dites on sort par la
porte que l'on veut moi je sors par la
porte de l'infirmerie ça veut dire quoi
c'est très acronique ouais non non parce
que
sortir par quelle porte
parce que j'étais blessé que je savais
que ça s'était un peu difficile et je
suis sorti par la porte de l'infirmerie
je suis venu là par hasard je suis sorti
un peu
sur un coup du sort je trouve que c'est
un peu normal normal que les choses se
commencent
comme elles sont commencées pour moi
avec un j'ai gagné comme disait un de
mes copains il dit j'ai gagné un
concours de circonstances et là
j'ai fini à l'infirmerie je suis sorti
par derrière et puis voilà c'était pas
si compliqué que ça se sépare c'est des
jeux c'est il y a rien de c'est mon
confond souvent le grave le sérieux
c'est sérieux mais c'est pas grave
bonne formule alors deux ans plus tard
en 1986 donc vous décidez de prendre une
retraite définitive vous faites cadeau
de votre trophée de vos maillots vous
distribuez tout et la seule chose que
vous n'oubliez pas c'est les gens avec
qui vous avez joué mais vous vous
délestez de de tous ces oripeaux de la
gloire oui parce que enfin je l'avais
fait déjà moi en chemin parce que je
trouvais que s'attacher à des des
breloques ou des trucs c'est pas très
important c'est c'est les souvenirs que
l'on a tout ce qui sert à se fabriquer
se fabriquer les les gens que vous
croisez c'est où les gens qui comptent
et cela on les donne jamais on les garde
pour soi alors après c'est une autre vie
d'abord comédien comédien je suis pas je
crois pas que ce soit dans mon caractère
en revanche la hauteur de lumière là où
ça marche super bien c'est le c'est la
sculpture la sculpture c'est autre chose
de la sculpture c'est certainement la
seule réponse est intéressante que j'ai
trouvé à la question essentielle et puis
j'ai surtout rencontré des gens
étonnant oui Albert Albert Ferro et il a
dit cela ce qui nous qui m'ont remis au
monde quoi c'est très étonnant de vous
voir sculpter avec des IPN j'étais jeune
je voulais faire les Beaux-Arts mais ça
faisait c'était pas bien à l'époque
c'était les cheveux longs les gens fils
de pilote on faisait plutôt un truc un
peu plus sérieux même si mon père était
un peu
à part quand même dans le il était
plutôt en voltigeur mais mais
la face était c'était ça faisait pas
partie du programme et mais bon et puis
donc j'ai toujours eu tu curiosité cette
curiosité des formes et des couleurs et
un jour j'ai rencontré donc Albert
ferrot qui était un homme merveilleux
qui chantait son atelier et j'en suis
jamais sorti je suis tombé amoureux de
son travail de sa famille de lui j'ai
acheté une maison à côté de chez lui
tous les jours j'étais là je me portais
les croissants et je vais je vais vous
aider il me dit mais qu'est-ce que tu
fais tes trucs et petit à petit voilà et
ça fait 35 ans que ça marche très bien
ça marche oui ça marche parce que je
suis ça m'empêche de dormir ça me
réveille quelquefois et ça me sens moins
moins stupide le soir quand j'ai fait
quelque chose je me sens un peu moins
idiot quoi vous êtes nostalgique de
l'époque de Casque d'or non non ça a été
merveilleux moment je crois qu'il faut
vivre puis
et puis des choses changent il faut te
il faut vivre avec son époque je suis
pas nostalgique sur Nostalgie des
copains parce qu'on avait on a c'est une
autre époque mais c'était bien et
aujourd'hui c'est bien aussi donc j'ai
une chance inouïe je suis très très
chanceux si c'était à refaire
Jean-Pierre qu'est-ce que vous ne feriez
pas pareil je suis un instinctif donc je
peux pas calculer alors je sais pas si
je peux pas calculer ce que je vais
faire je peux pas calculer un peu c'est
comme je fais une sculpture je sais pas
je sais pas je peux même pas calculer
comment j'aurais pu faire autrement je
fais ce que je peux c'est déjà pas mal
et donc je peux pas calculer dire ce que
j'aurais fait ou j'ai pas fait si
j'avais pas fait ce que j'avais fait je
serai pas ce qui je suis si j'étais pas
qui je suis je ferai pas donc ce que je
vais faire c'est un peu compliqué votre
question donc tout va bien le jour vous
allez disparaître qu'est-ce que vous
voulez qu'on marque sur votre tombe
comme comme épitaphe
à tout de suite ou à bientôt quelque
chose comme ça
à très vite à très vite toujours je sais
pas oui ou quelque chose je sais pas je
sais pas quelque chose qui me hante
même si j'ai deux petits garçons
aujourd'hui donc j'aimerais aller voir
longtemps mais bon c'est tout ça le
reste le reste j'ai eu beaucoup de
chance je souhaite à tous les enfants
d'en avoir un petit peu comme ça et
surtout de de partager un peu cette
fraternité du jeu sans tomber
qui donne un sens à la vie et
quelquefois un sens commun c'est encore
mieux alors c'est ça que je peux
souhaiter à mes enfants et à tous les
enfants merci j'étais très heureux de
rallumer la lumière sur vous Jean-Pierre
merci beaucoup gentil merci et pour être
sûr de ne rien rater de tube
abonnez-vous et mettez un pouce bleu